y aquí tenemos otro rearreglo o
transposición de un kart vocación pero
este es un poco más desafiante del lado
izquierdo tenemos nuestro alumno de
alquilo inicial o también conocido como
halogenuro de alquilo y lo calentamos
con agua para producir el alcohol
terciario que tenemos en la derecha
ahora el primer paso de este mecanismo
es la pérdida del grupo saliente
entonces estos electrones se van junto
con el bromo para formar el a neón
bromuro y al hacer eso le quitamos un
enlace a este carbono de color rojo con
lo que tendrá una carga formal positiva
entonces si dibujamos nuestro anillo de
6 miembros
el carbono de color rojo corresponde a
este carbono y ahora tiene una carga
formal positiva tenemos un kart vocación
y por acá tenemos dos grupos metilo
así que este es un kart vocación
secundario porque el carbono rojo está
directamente unido a otros dos carbonos
ok pero si analizamos nuestro producto
podemos ver que tenemos un anillo de 5
miembros no 6 y sabemos que en esta
reacción nuestro núcleo filo tiene que
ser el agua entonces el oxígeno en el
agua forma un enlace en nuestro producto
con este carbono déjenme resaltar ese
carbono de color azul ahí está y eso
significa que ahí es en donde debe estar
la carga formal positiva ese debe ser el
carb ocasión con el que se forma nuestro
producto
entonces dibujemos eso aquí tenemos
nuestro anillo de 5 miembros y el
carbono azul sería este carbono que
tenemos aquí y aquí es en donde debemos
de tener la carga formal positiva porque
el núcleo filo atacará al carbono azul
entonces déjenme dibujar una molécula de
por aquí para mostrar el ataque núcleo
físico esta es nuestra molécula de agua
tenemos dos pares de electrones libres
en el oxígeno y nuestro núcleo filo
ataca al electro filo para formar un
enlace entre el oxígeno y el carbono y
eso formará vamos a dibujarlo aquí aquí
tenemos nuestro anillo de 5 miembros y
por acá tenemos a nuestro carbono de
color azul y ahora dibujamos un enlace
con el oxígeno y el oxígeno está unido a
otros dos hidrógenos y aún tiene un par
de electrones libres lo que le da una
carga formal positiva ok y el último
paso de este mecanismo es la pérdida de
un protón ocurre una transferencia de
protón voy a escribir menos h más una
base como la molécula de agua entra y
toma uno de esos protones y así es como
obtenemos nuestro producto final pero
ahora pensemos en cómo podemos pasar del
carbó catión de la izquierda al carbó
catión de la derecha observen que el
kart vocación de la derecha es un kart
vocación terciario porque el carbono
azul está unido directamente a otros
tres carbonos así que es un kart
vocación terciario por lo tanto
necesitamos hacer algún tipo de real
regla para pasar de un kart vocación
secundario a uno terciario pero este
caso es diferente a cualquier otro
rearreglo transposición que hayamos
visto hasta ahora entonces veamos el
siguiente vídeo para que sea más claro
aquí tenemos el modelo de nuestro carbó
catión tenemos una carga formal positiva
en este carbono y solo he dejado un
hidrógeno en ese carbono para que sea
más fácil verlo ahora
para el regla del carbó catión voy a
tomar los electrones de este enlace y
romper el anillo para pasar de un anillo
de 6 miembros a uno de 5 con este
arreglo del carbó catión así hemos
cambiado la hibridación de los carbonos
aquí les tengo otro modelo para que
puedan ver mejor el carb ocasión ahora
el carbono con el hidrógeno tiene una
hibridación sp3 y este carbono tiene una
hibridación sp2 su geometría es plana
tomé algunas capturas del vídeo que nos
ayudarán a entender mejor el real regla
empecemos con esta imagen el carbono
rojo que resalte arriba este carbono
corresponde a este carbono y este
carbono de color lo pondré de color
verde corresponde a este de aquí
entonces en el vídeo tomamos estos
electrones y los movimos a este carbono
así que cuando dibujamos nuestro
mecanismo aquí arriba tomamos estos
electrones y los movemos al carbono rojo
así formamos un enlace entre el carbono
verde y el rojo mostremos eso en el
dibujo ahora tenemos un anillo de 5
miembros el carbono rojo corresponde a
este carbono y el carbono verde sería a
este carbón y vamos a decir que este
carbono es de color azul ahora
ese carbono azul aún no está unido al
carbono rojo entonces vamos a dibujarlo
aquí y después tenemos un grupo metilo
en este carbono así que el carbono azul
ahora es este carbono que corresponde a
este carbono en la imagen ok ahora vamos
con la imagen del centro vamos a ver el
carbono verde corresponde a este carbono
el carbono rojo corresponde a este y el
carbono azul es este de aquí así se
forma a nuestro carbó catión terciario
aquí tenemos una carga formal positiva
en el carbono azul y esto es lo mismo
verdad solo están dibujados de forma
diferente el carbó catión de la derecha
está un poco mejor pero es lo mismo
vamos a identificar esos carbonos aquí
el carbono rojo es este carbono y en la
imagen corresponde a este carbón el
carbono verde que es este carbono
corresponde a este y finalmente el
carbono azul que sera
este corresponde a este carbón ahora el
carbono rojo bueno regresemos a la
imagen de la izquierda el carbono rojo
en el que teníamos inicialmente la carga
formal positiva tiene una hibridación
sp2 pero observen que cuando pasamos
aquí ahora tiene una hibridación sp3
tenemos una geometría te trae drica
alrededor del carbono rojo y por otro
lado el carbono azul pasa de una
hibridación sp3 a una hibridación sp2
por eso les mostré el otro modelo
molecular en el vídeo porque este
carbono azul al ser un kart vocación
tiene una hibridación sp2 miren es este
carbono azul y tiene una geometría plana
a su alrededor espero que los modelos
les hayan ayudado a entender este
extraño rearreglo de carbó catión tan
desafiante veamos todo el mecanismo ok
el primer paso es la pérdida del grupo
saliente después tenemos un re arreglo
del carbó catión con
que pasamos de un kart vocación
secundario a un kart vocación terciario
y el siguiente paso es el ataque núcleo
físico en el que la molécula de agua
ataca al carbono que tiene la carga
positiva y ocurre una reacción ha sido
base en la que quitamos un protón para
formar nuestro producto